we already knew the ps4 neo was on the
way but it looks like Sony has a second
console up its sleeve I'm Tony and this
is your double dose of GameSpot news
update sony is holding a press event in
just a few weeks and the Wall Street
Journal says that this will be the
official unveiling of the ps4 neo
additionally the site reports that Sony
will reveal a new standard ps4 this news
came at the same time as gaming forum
neogaf rounded up several pictures of an
alleged ps4 slim the pictures show a ps4
with actual power and eject buttons in a
500 gigabyte sku sony has never
confirmed a slim model and development
but Eurogamer apparently got their hands
on one so that's almost certainly the
second console will see at the event
sony's press event is happening
wednesday September 7 all will be
revealed or confirmed at that time both
the neo and the slim sound interesting
so stay tuned to gamespot for when sony
does the unveiling and for all the
biggest playstation news you already in
the right place
you